at this point i think you know a little
bit about what multiplication is
or
multiplication
we're going to do in this video is to
give you just a ton of more practice and
start you on your
memorization of the multiplication
tables and if you watch enough khan
academy videos and hopefully you will in
the future you'll realize that i'm
normally not a big fan of memorization
but the one thing about multiplications
if you memorize your multiplication
tables that will start to do in this
video it'll pay huge benefits the rest
of your life so i promise you do it now
you'll never forget it and and the rest
of your life everything will be well i
don't want to make false promises to you
but they'll be better than if you didn't
memorize your multiplication tables so
what are the multiplication tables well
that's just
all of the different numbers times each
other so
let's actually do a little bit review so
if i say
what is 2 times 1 two times one
that is equal to two plus itself one
time so this is equal to just two
right that's two plus it's up one time i
don't have to say plus anything because
there's only one two there i could also
write this as one plus itself two times
so that's also one plus one well that
also equals two fair enough so two times
one is two and if you watch the last
video what's two times zero well that's
zero so you don't have to memorize your
zero multiplication tables because
everything times zero is zero or zero
times anything is zero so let's see
what's two times two
two times two
well this is equal to we're going to add
two to itself two times so that's two
plus two and there's only way to do that
i could say take this two and add it to
itself two times but it's the same thing
it was two plus two that's equal to four
what's two times three two times three
is equal to two plus two
plus two it can also be equal to
three plus three
right we learned in the previous video
the statement could be written either of
these ways and either case what's it
equal to well 3 plus 3 is the same thing
as 2 plus 2 plus 2 and that's equal to
6.
all right now what is 2 times 4
2 times 4
well that's equal to two plus two plus
two plus two and notice it's exactly
what two times three was
two times three
was that i have that here
but now i'm just adding another two to
it so if we're too lazy to sit here and
add oh two plus two is four four plus
two is six instead of doing that we
could say hey look we already know that
this thing over here this was six
we figured it out in the previous line
right there we figured out this is 6 so
we could just say oh 2 times 4 is going
to be 2 more than that which is equal to
8.
and you should hopefully see that
pattern as we go from 2 times 1
to 2 times 2
to 2 times 3 what's happening how much
are we going up by
from two to four we're going plus two
from four to six we're going plus two
and then from six to eight we're going
plus two so you could figure out what
two times five is even without doing the
addition two times five is equal to two
plus two plus two plus two
plus two could also be written as five
plus five
two times four could have been written
as four plus four as well
and what's that equal to we could add
all of these up we could add these two
up or we could just say it's going to be
2 more than 2 times 4.
so it's going to be 10.
i'll just i'll finish the two times
tables
and i think you see all of the patterns
that emerge from it so two times six
well it's going to be two plus itself
six times
uh let's see one two three four five
six which should also be equal to six
plus itself two times this could be
interpreted either way
and that's going to be equal to 12. once
again 2 more than 2 times 5
right because we're we're adding 2 to
itself one more time so it's going to be
2 more
let's keep going
so 2 times 7
2 times
7 is equal to
well instead of i could write 2 plus 2
plus 2 plus 2 this is getting tiring stu
plus 2 is that seven one two three four
five six seven
and that's the same thing as seven plus
seven which you may or may not know is
equal to fourteen
but this you could just say hey that's
going to be two more than twelve so
twelve plus one plus 2 is 12 plus 1 is
13 12 plus 2 is 14.
all right let's just keep going
2 times 8
2 times 8. i could do all of this
business here where i add the 2's or i
could say look it's just going to be 2
more than 2 times 7. so i could say it's
going to be 14 plus 2. i'm just adding 2
to that one so i could say it's 16 or i
could also say that's 8 plus 8
8 plus 8 that's also 16. i could have
done all the twos out but if you'd like
you could do that for for your own for
your own benefit and learning
all right
we're almost well we could go forever
right because there is no largest number
i could keep going you know keep two
times nine times ten times 100 key times
a thousand times a million but i'm going
to stop at 12 because that tends to be
what people need to memorize but if you
really want to be a math a mathlete you
might want to go up to 20.
let's go to 2 times 9
well it's going to be 2 more than 2
times 8 it's going to be 18.
or that's 9 plus 9. also 18. what's 2
times 10
and 10 times tables are interesting and
we're going to see a pattern there in a
second when we look at when we do try to
complete entire times tables
so two times ten two more than two times
nine it's twenty
right or we could also say that's ten
plus ten ten plus itself two times
now what's interesting about this this
looks just like a 2
with a 0 on it and you're going to see
that anything times 10 you just put a 0
on the right and you can think about why
that is this is you can view this as 2
tens is 20. that's what 20 is
we're almost done let's do 2 times 11.
2 times 11 is going to be 2 more than
this right here
it's going to be 22.
another interesting pattern i have the
number repeated twice a 2 and a 2
interesting something to to watch out
for and
as we as as we look at other
multiplication tables and then finally
it's not fine we could keep going two
times that's too dark of a color
two times twelve
2 times 12 is going to be 2 more than 2
times 11 as 24. we could have also
written that as 12 plus 12 or we could
say 2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 12
times it all gets you to 24.
so that's the two times tables and i
think you see the pattern every time you
multiply it by one higher number you
just add 2 to that number so now that we
see that pattern let's see if we can
complete a multiplication table
so what i'm going to do
i'm going to write all of the numbers
let's see
one i hope i have space for this one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
actually i'll just do it until nine well
i'll just keep going nine
actually i won't have space to do that
because i want you to see the entire
table so i'm gonna go until nine here
but i encourage you after this video to
complete it on your own maybe if we have
time i'll complete it here as well
so this are the first numbers that i'm
going to multiply and i'm going to
multiply it times 1
and 9. what i'm going to do is i'm going
to
so first of all actually i should have
written this
1 under what's 1 times 1. so this is the
way i'm going to view it whatever is 1
times 1 i'm going to write here well
that's 1.
what's 1 times 2 that's 2. what's 1
times 3 that's 3. 1 times anything is
that number so i could just write 4
7 8 9. right 1 times 9 is 9.
fair enough now let's do the two times
tables i'll do that in a blue actually
let me do one and that color and now in
maybe a darker blue i'll do the two
times table what's two times one well
that's two it's the same thing as one
times two notice these two numbers are
the same thing what's two times two
that's four
two times three is six we just did this
every every time you increment or you go
you multiply by a higher number you just
add by two two times four is eight same
thing as four times two two times five
is ten
two times six is twelve i'm just adding
two every time right up here i added one
from every step here i'm adding two
two times seven fourteen
two times eight
sixteen
two times nine
eighteen
all right
let's do
our three times tables i'll do it in
yellow
three times one is three
notice three times one is three one
times three is three these are the same
values
three times two
is the same thing as two times three
right three times three times two should
be the same thing as two times three
so it's six
and that makes sense three plus three is
six or two plus two plus two is six
so every time here we're going to
increase by three you see the pattern
three times three is nine
three plus three plus three
so i went from three to six to nine so
three times four is going to be twelve
i'm just adding three every time twelve
plus three is fifteen fifteen plus three
is eighteen
eighteen plus three is twenty-one
twenty-one plus three is twenty-four
twenty-four plus three is twenty-seven
so three times nine is twenty-seven
three times eight is twenty-four so if
you were to say eight plus eight plus
eight it would be 24.
let's see if i can so now i'm going to
speed it up a little bit now that we see
the pattern and you should do this on
your own and you really should memorize
everything we're doing you should
actually go all the way up to 12 in both
directions so let's see 4 times one
is four
i'm just going to go up by increments of
four so
four plus four is eight eight plus four
is twelve twelve plus four is sixteen
sixteen plus four is 20 20 plus 4 is 24
right 4 times 6 is 24
4 times 7 28 i'm just going up by 4 32
and 36
36 all right 5 times 1
5 times 1 is going to be let me do this
5 times 1 is going to be 5.
actually we know that anything well i
want to keep changing colors so i'll
just do it in rows like this 5 times 1
is 5. 5 times 2 is
5 times 3 is 15 i'm just going to
increase by 5. 5 times tables are very
fun as well because every number is he's
going to add if we multiply 5 times well
we'll learn about even and odd in the
future but every other number every
other number in its times tables is
going to end with a five and then every
other one is going to end with a zero
because if you add 5 to 15 you get 20
you get 25
fair enough
six times tables let me do it in green
six times one is six that's easy you add
six to that you get twelve you add six
to that you get eighteen you add six to
that you get twenty four you add six to
that you get 30. then you go 6 more 36
48 plus 6 is 54. so 6 times 9 is 54.
all right we're almost there seven times
one that's seven
seven times one is seven seven times two
is fourteen
seven times three twenty-one seven times
four twenty-eight seven times five
what's what's 28 plus seven let's see if
you add two you get to 30 then you have
five let's 35
7 times 6 42 7 times 7 49
7 times 8 7 times going to be 7 plus
this so it's 56
i always used to get confused between 7
times 8 being 56 and 6 times 9 being 54.
so now that i pointed out to you that i
always got confused between those two
it's your job not to be confused by
those two
7 times 8 you could say has the 6 in it
6 times 9 doesn't have the 6 in it
that's the way i think of it anyway 7
times 9 we're going to add another 7
here it's going to be 63 to do it in
that same color
all right we're at our eight times
tables
eight times one is eight
eight times two sixteen
twenty-four
right eight times three is twenty-four
and if we go to three times eight we
should also see the twenty-four yep it's
there all right these values are the
same so we're actually doing things
twice we're doing it when you do eight
times three and we're doing it when we
did three times eight
let's see eight times four we're going
to add eight to it 32 40
add another eight forty-eight
notice eight times six forty-eight
six times eight forty-eight
all right eight times seven well we
already pointed that one out that was
fifty-six
eight times eight sixty-four eight times
nine add eight to this is seventy-two
now we're at the nine times tables i'm
running out of colors
well maybe i'll reuse a color or two
i'll use the blue again nine times one
is nine nine times two eighteen nine
times three we actually know all of
these we could look it up in the rest of
the table because nine times three is
the same thing as three times nine is
twenty-seven
add nine to that twenty-seven plus 9 is
36.
36 plus 9 is
45. notice every time you add 9
you go almost up by 10 but 1 less than
that so up by 10 would be 46 and then
one less than that is 45 but anyway
we'll talk about notice the ones did
well i'll talk more about the future but
we go from a 9 8 7 6
5 on this digit on the second digit and
on the on the set the this digit here
you go one two three four so it's an
interesting pattern another interesting
pattern is the digits will add up to
nine three plus six is nine two plus
seven is nine we'll talk more about that
in the future and maybe prove that to
you
nine times six
fifty-four
that was this one as well 9 times 7
63 9 times 8 72 9 times 1 is 81. i don't
know if you can see that 81.
there you go
now i could keep going actually i should
keep going let me
well i i realize this video is already
pretty long in the next video i want you
to memorize this right now because this
is going to get you pretty far in the
next video i'm going to do the times
tables past nine
see you soon